[Música]
no me considero una persona miedosa
de hecho mi familia y amigos coinciden
en que tiendo a ponerme en situaciones
de riesgo
como el año pasado cuando visité sola un
barrio en santiago de chile que estaba
siendo mostrado en los medios de
comunicación como muy peligroso donde
asaltaban todos los días tenía problemas
de narcotráfico y que por esto estaba
siendo excluido de la acción de la
ciudad
cuando llegue al lugar me di cuenta de
que en realidad no era tan terrible como
estaba siendo mostrado de hecho me
encontré con una vida de barrio muy
linda donde los niños jugaban en los
parques había pequeñas tiendas pequeñas
panaderías y la gente caminaba por la
calle normalmente
seguí caminando y al cruzar una calle
toda esta vida de barrio desaparece
y me encuentro con un entorno desolado
muerto donde las casas estaban
completamente cerradas las tiendas
tenían rejas y no había nadie caminando
por la calle
observaba yo el cambio tan drástico
cuando de una de las casas cercanas a mí
sale una persona y comienza a seguirme
en aquel momento no le di mucha
importancia
pero conforme avanzaba esta persona se
iba acercando más a mí y podré ser muy
valiente pero no soy tonta y sé que si
esa persona hubiera querido hacerme daño
no había nadie en aquel lugar desolado
que hubiera podido ayudarme
así que salí lo más rápido que pude de
allí
en este momento ustedes deben de estarse
pensando
qué susto pediste
la verdad es que no sentí miedo
ahora deben de estar pensando pues que
lo que estás
y probablemente tengan razón
la cuestión con el miedo es que es algo
muy subjetivo que depende de cada quien
depende del lugar donde crecimos y nos
desarrollamos depende de nuestras
vivencias personales un miedo puede
construirse de forma colectiva o puede
construirse de forma individual es algo
que compartimos todos los seres humanos
es más les puedo asegurar que en este
momento todos los que estamos aquí le
tememos algo que no es real
algo que no está pasando y que
probablemente nunca vaya a pasar
todo aquello que yo había observado en
este lugar desolado me hablaba de un
terrible terrible miedo por estar afuera
y eso había hecho que se abandonaran los
espacios públicos
con todo esto en mi cabeza empecé a
preguntarme varias cosas
porque yo no había sentido miedo
que hacía que estas personas que vivían
en ese lugar si tuvieran mucho miedo
y como arquitecto urbanista como el
miedo afecta mi profesión como el miedo
afecta el diseño de los barrios
entonces decidí estudiar tres variables
que son muy básicas a la hora que
nosotros los diseñadores urbanos
pretendemos cambiar la calidad de vida
de un lugar estudia el campo visual
porque te permite vigilar estudia la
iluminación que tiene que ver con la
percepción de temor durante la noche y
estudie la manutención de los espacios
verdes y las plazas
como se podrán imaginar aquel lugar
lleno de vida del barrio tenía una
iluminación muy adecuada
las luminarias estaban posicionadas
exactamente en aquellos lugares que
podían ser riesgosos durante la noche el
campo visual era muy adecuado porque te
permitía ver lo que estaba pasando y las
madres podían vigilar a sus hijos que
jugaban en las plazas desde sus casas y
estas plazas estaban muy bien iluminadas
están muy bien mantenidas tenían juegos
y por eso la gente los usaba
cotidianamente
en cambio aquel lugar desolado y muerto
del barrio tenía un campo visual
obstruido habían árboles que estaban tan
crecidos que no te dejaban ver al otro
lado de la calle
la iluminación era muy tenue y producto
del vandalismo había áreas que estaban
completamente oscuras durante la noche y
los parques se habían convertido en
puntos de delincuencia donde te
asaltaban y las pandillas se reunían a
consumir alcohol y drogas
les dije que soy arquitecto urbanista y
como tal tenía que ver el diseño del
barrio
aquel lugar vivo tenía un diseño de
calles muy regular
mientras que el lugar muerto y desolado
tenía una curvatura en sus calles muy
pronunciada que hacía que su diseño
fuera irregular esto arquitectónicamente
hablando puede llegar a causar lo que
nosotros le decimos lugares trampa que
son lugares que propician la ocurrencia
de delitos porque le permite a un
asaltante oa un violador esconderse
permite que un grupo de delincuentes se
reúna a vender drogas y que nadie los
vea
esto porque son lugares que son muy
obscuros o porque son plazas que nadie
visita o porque son lugares que nadie
puede vigilar
acciones que se pueden corregir
precisamente con estas variables básicas
que yo estaba estudiando y que en este
lugar no se estaban llevando a cabo
este lugar estaba sufriendo las
consecuencias de un mal diseño
y aunque todo esto me da una mirada muy
buena de lo que estaba pasando
territorialmente no contestaba una
pregunta que era muy importante
porque la gente se comportaba tan
distinto en un lugar tan cercano
entonces regrese al lugar y empecé a
conocer esta gente
ahí conocí a doña amelia una señora que
tenía 50 años viviendo en este lugar y
me decía que vivía feliz y tranquila
conocí a la señora laura y ella me
contaba que durante las noches salía a
ver unos partidos de fútbol que se
hacían cerca de su casa
regresaba por la madrugada y no tenía
ningún problema conocí a mucha gente que
no le ponía llave a su casa porque no
era necesario
todos estos vecinos tenían historias de
terror de aquel lugar desolado porque
ahí te robaban porque ahí vendían droga
y preferían no irse a meter allá
también me di cuenta de que todos los
vecinos se conocían se reunían una o dos
veces a la semana a tener talleres de
costura o talleres de deporte tenían
mucha confianza entre ellos se habían
convertido en una comunidad y esto había
despertado en ellos una voluntad por la
participación ciudadana se habían
reunido para juntos trabajar y diseñar
su barrio
donde ellos veían un lugar que podía ser
peligroso habían solicitado iluminación
cuando ellos veían que sus parques
necesitaban manutención también la
solicitaban o bien ellos mismos cortaban
césped o daban árboles y podían arreglar
algunos juegos que se descomponían en
los parques tenían meses trabajando en
unos murales preciosos que ahora
adornaban el barrio
se habían reunido habían trabajado su
espacio público y se habían apropiado de
él
entonces me di cuenta de algo que no te
enseñan en la universidad
para que un proyecto de arquitectura y
urbanismo realmente funcione tenemos que
iniciar construyendo la arquitectura
social aquella que construye comunidades
y que les permite apropiarse de su
espacios públicos
existe un trabajo de seguridad que va
más allá de más policías y más cámaras
de vigilancia nosotros como arquitectos
tenemos que velar siempre por que
nuestros proyectos sean seguros pero el
trabajo más importante es el que tenemos
como sociedad es el de apropiarnos sin
miedo de nuestros espacios públicos es
cuidarlos y evitar que entre en ellos la
violencia
vivimos en momentos de mucho miedo sobre
todo en américa latina pero no podemos
permitir que el miedo se convierta en
nuestro estilo de vida y vivir
encerrados en nuestras casas y en
nuestras oficinas
por eso los invito a que recuperemos
nuestros espacios públicos los invito
para que reforcemos la arquitectura
social y podamos construir juntos
barrios más seguros
gracias